try that again squeeze squeeze hey man
I'm Lenny that's an old reference
hey man I'm Captain America what what
double [ __ ] I'm Hulk
how about like Tony Stark there I'll be
Tony Stark you the Captain America music
oh hey man I'm Tony Stark actually it
should be if I'm Tony Stark you should
be and I'm Steve Rogers here we go we're
gonna get this right sooner or later
here we go and take 19 action hey man
I'm Tony Stark hi and welcome to another
exciting episode of what's in the box
he's not gonna shield you from this one
and and aye-iron
is I got no plan for that so me and Jay
are going to unbox virtually and play
Jay and Silent Bob mall brawl it's a
game that the folks that interrobang is
anything in inter bang entertainment put
together with spoony bard productions
man in inter bang is doing this what's
the other game they're doing Jay and
Silent Bob chronic lung punch so it's
taking them a while to build that so
they put out this mini game in advance
to raise money for that game and so it's
done very very well now Jay has played
the game have you not yes I have not
played the game at all I'm very much
looking forward to it
I am a not a game boy like yourselves
I'm a side-scrolling guy I know this
clown and a lot of you out there are
like first-person shooters and [ __ ] like
that a little bit of fortnight a little
bit of five five nine six night whatever
the [ __ ] you guys are playing that's way
too advanced for me
I'm from the 80s 70s and 80s so I love a
side-scrolling game and that's what the
good folks have put together for us
today I have literally never played this
I don't know the action I don't know the
control so you know he you have played
so you're gonna see a pro and you're
gonna see a neophyte do we play our cell
where do we play each other because in
the game Jane Samba mall brawl you can
play as by yourself correct you can play
with other people correct yes and you
can pick either J or Silent Bob what is
that little video are they waiting are
we being raided yeah by rating meaning
they like right away right away you
twitch pirates come on in join the party
mister Muse here is a regular twitch
streamer can we turn the music down a
little bit is it over there I know a lot
of people out there disappointed right
now they're like man I only came to this
[ __ ] session because I thought Jake
could figure out the [ __ ] headsets
but who knew a lot of bells and whistles
happen jumping oh there's another one
people subscribing another subscriber
looking all you subscribers you need me
you need me here man I can't bring you
subscribers and stuff this is uh this
this is I just want to take this
opportunity to thank the twitch audience
out there who's embraced the
because he's got his own little TV
studio in here now he's own little
broadcast world you should see him
running around it's like it's like like
Joan Cusack in broadcast news he runs
around slides under drawers naturally
that's an old-ass movie that none of you
are gonna remember or know the reference
to but it's really nice to see him
embrace something like this like where
he's just like oh I'm doing I he'd like
I'd be like hey man come over he's like
a can I'm streaming so how nice for a
guy who spent most of his career being
told what to do by somebody who didn't
even know what he was doing in the first
place instead now he gets to build his
own thing that I'm coming to visit so
that's very sweet and you don't get to
do that unless you guys sit around and
ding and [ __ ] like that whatever the
[ __ ] raid us things that sound very
hostile but in fact are very good and
it's good for the boy look look I mean
he granted how old are you he's 45 year
old boy what is that says and it gives
people Lord mu B says I thought it was
Holly Hunter in broadcast news number 1
I'm thrilled anyone got the reference
Holly Hunter she didn't slide under the
drawer that was Joan Cusack where she's
trying to get the tape to the broadcast
room right now I'm talking way too much
about a movie that came out in the 80s
and that none of your were alive for in
stuff but thank you for following
through on that um how nice thank you
got a bunch of subs how sweet I saw
those graphics and put what I say the
first thing I said you pay that person
cuz that's quality and he said no it
doesn't fray I'm like you better send
him something nice man you start paying
a missus that [ __ ] look good man I
thought it'd look real professional [ __ ]
and more of what people do that the less
this guy has to like you know rely on
his own wits and then his [ __ ] gets
better like I saw a little box that I
saw the future one too which was dope
what's a
box that he did the shutters right thank
you
somebody said can I can Kevin can you
scroll back up they're going so fast
hey can Kevin read my name goddamn yoga
hoser goddamn yoga hoser was like
Stanley said in the movie alright man
here we are in twitch land we've caught
up a little bit how you feeling I'm sure
a lot of people are disturbed by the
lack of social distancing that we're
practicing him and I are like
practically in each other's left.we we
don't live in the same house mind you
but we live close enough and we've been
interacting for since the [ __ ] thing
and plus we make out on a regular basis
so if we haven't you know giving each
other to Cole but yet relatively oh sure
we're gonna be okay they went to Vegas
yeah they went to their house like you
keep freaking Muse over we're gonna die
and they left no they were tired of like
they just were buying a house in Vegas
when everything happened and so they
couldn't even go to the opening stuff so
they waited a long time and now they
drove to Vegas and stuff so yeah but
we've kept very close quarantine
communities between both our houses so
they're putting more pictures of us up
somebody did ding
a raid that's when people are like we're
coming near you boy did a pump like that
Oh we'll get at it this is good Oh is do
we have to watch our language and stuff
chicken nugget ass fine chicken nugget
ass how's my mom doing good man thank
you for asking
Wow what does that mean the hypetrain
Jake Oz says is ass to mouth social
distancing noted mom this is like being
in Vegas all the lights and then Bing
and you won and [ __ ] this is
fantastic man no wonder you never leave
your little man cave you'll amuse cave
why would you who wants to interact with
real live people when you can get all
the love right here and get on the hype
train so right now the hype train level
four is growing yes and you're saying
you've only ever been on the hype train
at level five that's the highest I thank
you for all the subscribe I'm getting
jealous here man join me at that Kevin
Smith Club from Jegs News this is
awesome man look at people jumping on
and this is dope man like it's where he
did tell me about this for a while and
I'm familiar with like some of the
twitching that he does because he's done
it in my house but he's got like this
command center set up looks like [ __ ]
me and live for your diehard you look
like the Warlock bro and like you know
the the interactivity thing is really
[ __ ] dope all right so level four can
we should we wait until we get to level
five to start the game
no keep going let's see the remote level
complete level for 81% come on bring out
the choo-choo let me tell you something
if you're watching this on mine there's
a picture again we keep popping up this
is great oh my god I feel like I'm in
Vegas man it's like Circus Circus
when's the waiter come by with free
drinks if you're watching this on my
youtube or on my there's another dude
ding for those who are watching on my
YouTube and or my Facebook all these
dings and stuff this is from Jay's
twitch we're hosting this today's show
are these people rich are you rich
because he gifted he gave 10 people
subscriptions do you can you do it this
is it but with money or can you do it
like credits so he's literally given
some money bro why do you why do you
leave this oh that duck is cool if I was
you I'd never leave this room and why do
you need a marriage or a child you have
all these people who love you and and
give you subs because you're in here on
time I can see why you being here it is
like it's like Vegas bro it's very their
life's everywhere in any I go antic City
not knocking Atlantic City but the all
the action of Vegas like I feel like we
should go out on the strip get a [ __ ]
dog I'll get a vegan dog you get dog
then we come back in why are we going to
the strip
we'll just [ __ ] like go go to the
high rollers table and [ __ ] don't
bring us food and [ __ ] this is fun look
at the artwork say Brady drew us where'd
you get them
so gifted and look there's from our
movie yeah we make movies sometimes
[Music]
where are these drawings comes I tell
you kids I am [ __ ] floored
I'm flabbergasted this is awesome
[Music]
Jay Mewes has been live for 14 minutes
and 13 seconds and he's still ain't done
nothing interested show him your Weiner
count
hey kids once you famous we know you
don't do that here right he's like I'll
do that here I do that on pornhub
I'll join there and show them my camera
suite this is man thank you
what does that mean what do we win what
are we on the [ __ ] hypetrain
get on the hot train get on the hot
trend do to get on the hot train no
wonder people like sign on and never
leave man like who would want to [ __ ]
with the real world one you could do
this and our people nice on in your chat
or people like you suck at these games
Muse there's a picture of me there's a
bunch of
satin sheet says I bully him sometimes
they get in your face like you suck at
this game
Jane sound about pinball please I would
like that I'm all for that make it
please it goes some fact let me see she
we should play the game though right
because I'm gonna start reading I gotta
see what I guys see the one dude who she
said is that oh I see I never used it
you better touch him for a break
everything I don't ever really use a PC
somebody was like watching Kevin be
oldest fun content because I'm like this
is so strange
it's so unfamiliar to me what do you
mean you play a video game with a
stranger I think it's I think we're done
we just stopped playing it was very
funny oh I'm train is getting ready to
pull out the station kids I don't know
what I'm talking about but he just said
the word so I'm gonna follow through cuz
we are about to play our damn game man
drink it straight up vodka on the rocks
ladies and gentlemen get drunk for this
[ __ ] weed I'm gonna get drunk now I'm
just kidding I'm drinking period which
is little bougie probably more relatable
if I was drinking vodka but I don't
drink unless donor I'm not allowed to
say that on Twitter so it's over so I'm
going to tell everyone really quick guys
it'll tell us how many we have such
drunk support level 5 completed watch it
says yes
- sobs do 10,000 [ __ ] guys yeah well
I'll take two I love you guys who's that
you guys inspire me to try to be an
actor and one day wish to work if you
guys what is that the community is my
b-day I am going to be 25 last week I
won a prize five minutes dungeon from
you guys I cannot wait love Jason from
Denver
Hal is talking to us the computer step
away
open the pod bay doors out I can't leave
that keV no what is that
why did we hear somebody thank you for
the five thousand bits bro 47 Easter oh
my god somebody just said me using
wishing well and in yoga hosers was
genius
wait do I roll this hold on Dennis
Johnson says wishing well was awesome
and yoga's coming man thank you I know
it's a few years ago I'm chip but I
appreciate that kind of feedback all
right man so we should dive in a game
before people I was I was freaking out
picking the computer was taken over I
was like oh my god it's achieved
awareness it's like Skynet and [ __ ] like
that
oh the dummy where he's like hey Doge
Arvest Jarvis and then later on Friday I
didn't think it was a Jarvis I thought
it was somebody like I thought the
computer was just I am aware humans need
to be stopped before you kill each other
and then like we had locked in this room
together
which I honestly wouldn't mind man like
we got locked in this room we got air
conditioning in this buff artery usually
feel uncomfortable it is here air
conditioning we could probably order
some post mates if we need to stay here
forever you got a bathroom here alright
so we play chow as they said in the
movie wargames shall we play a game are
we playing here we go and they see what
we see we're getting raided it's a raid
alright look at this Jay and Silent Bob
Bob ball who made this again inter-gang
entertainment that's Justin and and of
course Elias he played Elias in clerks
to Trevor they came to us years ago and
said Amy I want to do a James Olmos
great to see you guys failed in darkness
Jay and Silent Bob has been tasked with
sabotaging a cheesy game show on public
access television having succeeded in
their quest our heroes must now evade
security and leave them all the quick
swoosh edding it's light something it's
silently shedding its lights on yeah it
looks like a TV this is dope and it's a
snoo goons on it as well
okay the good folks at spoony bard
productions they were the ones that
actually made the side scroller with
interrobang you always want to give
credit things to that
start game so two players
malas valve we get to pick our
characters after this which controllers
which I'm comfortable playing at you I
play work you like a puppet for years so
playing you here cannot wait chapter one
hit stop truth or date right so what are
the oh this is fantastic it's like
playing in the tar you I'm J I can't be
you so that's X is a punch square is a
rectangle by the rectangle triangle does
nothing and so it's these three buttons
and then do any of the top buttons do
anything
let's just take a moment to appreciate
the fact that like you and I start this
[ __ ] 26 years ago and for 26 years like
it wasn't the main goal but we'd always
be like man how come nobody ever doing
song Bob game they've done the game and
now we get to play I get to play with
myself as myself in front of people on
Twitter to come out
I took a move Canadian style home we got
them we never even gotten a real fight
in real life
yeah now your weapons being used against
you son of a [ __ ]
what sir let me stop look at our
strengths and I love ya so I'm about
halfway know I'm Bob I'm less than happy
without half how do we reach go [ __ ]
best time ever had that looks like wall
I mean is he oh man I didn't know other
be jumping
like a cup of white guys fighting some
african-americans in the mall this one
the oh my god
don't want to be a fool man like
Geoffrey I would like yeah I got one
thing oh I got some good at will you get
that box
yeah yeah
what's his in what do you mean it's over
just like mall rats it tanked as the box
office gosh
damn it okay
so is this what people do on Twitch they
plug you play games and but I mean like
like in my world here
so you better get this ice cream looking
sexy well I thank you Matt I believe I'm
doing a podcast with Matt momentum and
I'm at MIT I'm in the plaintiff
yeah one punch in the face they call me
one punch man come on kids come at me
come at me I don't care how old you are
face gonna saw me I thought you Shana
buck oh my god since this is the 90s
nobody's got a cell phone the mall
filming you beating up children
five kicks all right kicks yeah hit them
with that yeah we're going there's
another box
yeah now I got you son of a [ __ ] come
on damn you LaForest Irene has two kills
lost my virginity while watching you
oh my god I feel so accomplished I know
we're not supposed to do this during the
quarantine but I say we slap it quarters
to the dome just like in real life
oh [ __ ]
yeah you're dead [ __ ] try ollying a
grave I got to tell you kids this is the
[ __ ] greatest day of my life around
them all beating people up in a way that
I wanted to when I was a kid but never
had a chance to instead this is pretty
amazing pretty amazing I just got a text
and said masters in the universe episode
4 animatic has been sent my email so
when I'm done here I'm gonna go feed
oh my god kicking them kicking that cow
kick him utterly kicking him utterly
tell you man it's really good no Bob's
down for count stay alive I will find
you
wait in front of the burning flesh
tanning salon continue it starts at 7:00
you guys are amazing
watch Jin Silent Bob lead with first
time today
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
kids I suck I suck at Silent Bob and I
suck as Kevin Smith here that you got
more space to come through here all
right we're going back into it because
who [ __ ] marriage [ __ ] work who needs
any of that I'm gonna play this game for
the rest of my life
all right here we go man continuing with
our double dragon adventure through the
mall yeah
this is our mall it's small or Nothing
danly the best one raised of course but
I remember in the beginning Universal
didn't want you remember they were like
we're not but you can't bring your
[ __ ] body like you want a real actor
I'm like music so they you know Jake we
held these auditions Jay got the part
over everybody else he was up against
like the studio didn't want him they
wanted record Meyer or Seth Green open
wound up working on robust so they you
know they were like we had this pizza
party where everybody was up to the park
and so Jason that day the studio you
know I was like he's killing me
now I got him off his board give me her
[ __ ] stupid board oh I hate her I
hate you I'm gonna hollow your [ __ ]
ass
so Jason OH
so kick kick kick kick kick kick try and
keep it all and he took me out I'm down
you guys stay alive so Jason in the
pizza party like the studio's like
alright we like him but where we shot
the movie you got to bring him out
yourself and he can't we're not give him
a hotel room he's got Spain your hotel
room but when we see the first day of
dailies if we don't like him fired and
Breckin Meyer or seven is gonna be
watching so Jay was there for a month
rehearsing with everybody not getting
paid for the rehearsal period not having
his own room he was sleeping on much
boring stuff and so the first thing we
shot with him the first day was when you
know Trish is he gives Trish the tape
that was shot and then we shot something
else and those dailies went to Universal
to our executives and we had to wait to
find out what if they didn't like that
then we were gonna have to reshoot that
scene mercifully they loved my happy
memory I met many but one of them was
the day that like they said yes good
once they approve yeah yeah Jim and
Shawn were like you know we go it was a
big deal judy was like look we want
somebody who's been in more movies on
this day and when they said yes when
they were like
hit this dude this [ __ ] skateboard oh
I did my swirly we did a movie pop-up
restaurant out here in Los Angeles last
month for charity
[Music]
we're gonna go to know us without you a
charity out here people work in the
restaurant industry I'm back I could
help and so the folks who did save by
the safe gave it up birdie
saved by the by the bell pop-up
restaurant that they did not too long
ago
Darren doing this as well and so they
were like let's do a movies pop-up so we
did a pop-up delivery system where
people could order food to be delivered
to their house movie a movie meal but it
went so well that we are doing for real
movies pop-up restaurant
I guess as soon as they let us open
which sounds like it might be July well
maybe soon as the restaurant but get
that board get that board Jay talk you
have to do it oh god oh god oh god I'm
getting too you won't move oh I hate the
skateboarders oh my god
it was great seeing her laugh at the
same jokes I did when I was raised Dogma
to will never happens is Dylan Basie
yeah can't happen we don't know in that
way I don't know in any of the movies
but we get to play again when we die it
just means we get to play again you got
to flip the script and be positive
yes so a long time it's my job to hit
you I gotta say I legit love
I am of the game oh they can't hear you
so let's pull you're getting closer
the miners sorry everybody
jeez I was just blown up how good you're
doing and now they're like you're
ruining it
well I got one thing left let me get the
burger get that burger I'm gonna he
killed me now move I move you stay alive
get in there yeah yeah - those two
weapons try to get him - oh yeah yeah
live live through this just like hole
dude live through this just like
Courtney Love TARDIS now skateboard [ __ ]
you you're back you're back oh I'm back
so yeah did you see me grab his head and
beam in the [ __ ] face damn Skippy
[ __ ] you cow says this vegan kicked and
kill give me alive is amazing this is
the greatest day of my life turn around
turn around turn around turn around yeah
turn around how dare you how dare you
how dare you stop exactly chairs are
coming in the door and going out the
window
yeah beat it [ __ ] alright I lived I'm
gonna pull you back in the next screen I
hope oh yeah hit him hit him kill him
kill him quick kill him now yeah BAM
i'ma stay alive bro stay alive in front
of burning flesh you and this guy all
you do is knock him off his board yeah
take that skateboard hit him hit him
yeah we're gonna live or if this is
furthest we've gotten Oh ladies sorry
lady
what do you don't know her way to the
first day stock full course I just fell
out of her chair ass haha
this games clever watch this don't feel
weird when we're two white guys and
we're beating up a couple black guys in
the mall that's just not
but don't feel like my mall never my
experience in the mall it's odd I don't
feel bad about beating up the kids
whoa oh there's a box there's a box of
the stick yeah first these guys come out
don't listen to me I'm not sure yes wasy
oh oh oh my god through that oh damn I
got one kick oh my god would another
keep this snake I'm dead it's all you I
was very sweet thank you for kind words
I wish I'd met you at the Toronto
Roadshow so that did stay alive killed
by Patrick Swayze deadly drag continuing
oh we go back to the beginning well
that's fine mr. optimistic says we get
to we get to learn how to be better at
this clerks 10th anniversary you can
send it to an email
I mean an address that you want to send
and we could try to get Kevin this sign
Tapley if you send it to Jay here I'm
happily sign I live right around the
block wah wah wah wah
someone said Jersey girl too
and who said that Ben Affleck I don't
know if that's ever gonna happen kids
although technically I'll be honest with
you if you want to see Jersey girl -
it's called Jay and Silent Bob reboot
it's a movie about being a dad and
that's kind of what yours
this guy triple kicked me in the face
I'm so glad he's dead I don't know I'm
gonna grab your bottle yeah Jane saw Bob
reboot very much like Jersey girl just
way more dirty words hate my heart
because the good kids you got to go for
that box oh please I'm gonna try to get
the skateboarder with my new energy
watch I know skateboarders gonna come
out got me again
oh and I'm dead shut up dead oh we got
me you go one more
man you got we suck at our own game kids
but that's got to feel good cuz somebody
out there watching it's like why am I
better at the Jay and Bob game and Jay
and Bob are you gosh-darn yoga hoses
I'll tell you man it's hard not to just
sit around and read all the writing that
people do yeah hit him with his own
skateboard I love that
you can kick it kick it kick it kick it
kick it kick it kick it kick it kick
kick
hit you with a stick kick it kick right
in the face right the mask right in the
mask good bye Jason
[Music]
loving this game where can they buy it
steam on Steam and they can play it on a
twitch you guys get on the switcher
steam and it's 15 bucks little man yeah
there you go
right in the face with a bottle I hit
you right in the [ __ ] face with a
buck Oh give us the details I heard the
first part give us the details on
Mallrats to finished writing twilight of
the Mallrats we're working through all
the deal type stuff now it is I love it
Brody Bruce Renee comes back Willam Gwen
ts Oh Jay and Silent Bob Shannon
Hamilton you give me that skateboard no
you [ __ ] get away damn yeah now I hit
you with their [ __ ] skateboard and
I'm alive oh [ __ ] oh I'm gonna die here
if I could just kick a penny killed man
you never brings me back when I'm alive
I get him back here we go
I was trying alright enough to [ __ ]
talk in mah mah rats everybody you see
on the poster returns yeah I got hit
escape over with
I'm hitting you with your skateboard
comeback BAM right in your [ __ ] face
how dare you touch Silent Bob you you
you hit kick kick kick kick kick kick
kick kick punch punch punch punch punch
punch I love when I grab his head and
[Music]
how'd you like a nice wine punch
I did the twirly fair yeah I hit him in
the [ __ ] hit him in the dick hit him
in the dick
hit him in the dick dick dick I hate AHA
hitting you hit me with your board yeah
yeah
take a quick drink kicking ass is
thirsty work let me tell you something I
know it's self-serving but I [ __ ]
love this game I scream get that ice
cream son oh my god the skateboard guy
Hayden Hayden Hayden wouldn't want to
date him
give me your board yeah hit him with his
hello from from USA to Britain we are
both staying happy and healthy thank you
for asking
oh he got me in a corner
you [ __ ] cow Toys R Us tired thank
you for the donation of five bucks
little man hundred cheatcode what do you
do with the money I do it yeah they give
you five bucks where you do it that five
bucks could you owe me like baba nickel
bag of [ __ ] the BAM give that board oh
no don't you touch that board
I hate these kicking taken don't get
back up on the board uh-huh
mall rats they have a real good reason
to be at the mall this time of course
because you know in real life
look at me grabbing his head and kicking
him in the face
turn around sound buff kick kick kick
kick I said kick kick kick kick kick
how dare you hit me with that bottle and
I'll pick up the bottle and I hit you
with beat them up together JC Bob stop
always back on the board
oh ho hey kids this week on that Kevin
Smith Club I saw somebody asking about
moose jaw's if you go to that Kevin
Smith Club all week I've been reading
peace oh [ __ ] the reading pieces of the
script for people out loud and stuff on
a show I do called wake-and-bake
so if you're so curious about Jesus kick
kick kick kick you [ __ ] prick don't
you do that give me that stick and then
we'll both beat you up together if
you're if that sounds cool to you wake
and bake is the show is that that Kevin
Smith Club and you get to hear what
moose jaw's is gonna sound like I'm
reading all the Jay and Silent Bob
scenes from loose jaws because I'm
pulling them out of moose jaw's kicked
out yeah there was a special special
special he's getting ready to charge
I do big thank you
oh my god how nice no wonder you sit
here and play games oh there's a nice
[ __ ] by the way the computer voice you
don't even have to read writing and you
just hear it being that [ __ ] punch me
in the face we should get a burger from
the ski oh [ __ ] geez that grabs it dude
now I'm dead oh my god oh they're gonna
kill me I don't like it I want to win I
know it's just want to be a winner just
one
we've been streaming for an hour people
are still hanging out you still got like
800 people watching yeah kick some ol
ass probably sitting there going you
guys I just got a message to you play
and one hour until Berlanti pitch I have
a ver lantee pitch ji-sun try to get us
some work words are fun and games
playing mall brawl but sooner or later
we gotta go back to work man once they
open this world up so I'm doing a pitch
for a birth auntie Xiu
yeah man I got a cool idea a very cool
idea it's not for a whole show it's for
like one episode of it but it's gonna be
badass so I got that pitch at five
o'clock of your mind so I can't it's for
now so I can't like get lost here
otherwise you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
Swayze yeah I'm like hey man I doubt
we'll be on the call but it's a cool
thing that they're asking me about bang
hit twice in the face with a bottle
rug munchers this is where get him hit
him hit him oh he killed me avenge me
Hef night maybe they'll let me back in
this probably not is the ninja the ninja
comes out stars with a bang don't let
him get far away he starred you right in
the [ __ ] mush don't let don't die he
died I said don't
did you not hear me say don't god you
did the exact opposite welcome in raid
peeps love watching these two playing
games amazing childhood heroes says
shrimping thank you thank you makes me
feel old but good
we gotta beat this I lived this
adventure I have to be able to play this
I have to be able to win do either of
you smoke anymore are you both too old
for that she had live column in the 420
a half the column in I'm high as we
speak I smoke all the time
Jason is clean and sober he's in fact
July is coming up on his 10 year sober
anniversary man which is huge but I
smoke weed erryday as our elders father
and we have our own Weed Man if you're
ever in California get snoogantay blue
cheese or a berserker Jay and Silent
Bob's Weed Man powered by caviar gold so
yeah I still smoke like crazy if I was
playing this game without him here if it
was just me in a room I'd be smoking
like nuts I probably wouldn't be able to
play cuz I'm smoking so much
we're actually when we move down to the
screen these [ __ ] skate rats
we will you see we both get a memo I
here comes this Chinese ninja throwing
star Chinese throwing stars out oh oh oh
I grabbed about a head and I kicked him
in the face yes no more shuriken for us
I hate I'm dead it ain't right man right
bring that sweet weed Colorado Kevin he
says hopefully our bar boys at to caviar
gold they make our wheat hopefully
they'll be bringing into Colorado soon
failures just success training said Lord
movie we will oh my god that's so sweet
thank you for the damn kind words Jason
does it for the tips I just do it for
the kind words man is that what are you
doing for I did it all for the nookie
what the noogie what the nookie here we
go
how dare you hit me in the face oh boy
did my my swirling fists you spin me
right round baby right round kids oh my
god I wish I had a weapon so I could oh
I got this one's done let's get this
sucker yeah we got him we got him you
ain't throwing any stars no shuriken
no sure kid go to the box go to the box
i watch out for the cow oh yeah goodbye
cow yeah well you go forward
oh yeah I hit you with your [ __ ]
board oh you knocked me on my ass and
you killed me you're on your own
oh the board boys are back these dirty
board boys these dirty skate skate rats
verse the mall rats it's a battle of the
rats meanwhile I'm gonna read that was
the non-vegan movie you ain't kidding
Lana my blood circumcircle seal says
Lord movie Kevin are you a sativa or an
indica kinda guy says Jeff BMW I smoke
at all but I prefer sativa but I also
like to he's going to pee I also like to
work through snow goons run oh my god
snowgoons run thank you you've been on
the they mentioned abuse queue message
board which is something long time ago
kids back in like 1995 the internet
wasn't everywhere in fact there was a
time where you could say like oh I did
the Internet
like what do you mean like I went to
every site because it was so early so in
1995 after mall rats came out in tanked
Ming Chen from comic book men he built
the view ski website for us he had built
a clerks fan site and I loved it so I
reached out to him and say hey man can
you build me do you think it will blaze
up on your wheat we need some
legalization badly over here yeah no
doubt hopefully the whole country goes
legal that don't seem like it's
happening anytime soon before oh my god
I hit the button
but can you pause it [ __ ] I'm not for
that pause Billie's back so I forget
what I was talking about now before I
got interrupted by the computer boys
this is a good story what was that story
I was telling somebody remind me I hit a
[ __ ] pothole so I can't remember what
I was talking about yeah Oh Ming Chen so
Ming Chen built the bsq message board
for us beater ski website and the
message board nice to hang out on that
message board for years just interacted
with folks like this long before
something like twitch existed now at
that Kevin Smith club.com we have a
discord board Brandon happy birthday sir
I'm sorry you got laid off if it's any
consolation whatsoever I - I'm currently
unemployed I'm trying to find that next
gig I don't have many jobs it's like I'm
handing math guy Ike if I write a scrip
for myself I could make a movie maybe if
I could track the money down but I - the
other day I was like reading the
unemployment numbers and I was like wow
is a lot of unemployment right now and
Jason's wife Jordan runs our company
Jordan goes you're your [ __ ]
unemployed and I said well no I'm not
and then she said where's your next job
coming from and I was like well there's
but what about ending it and then I
realized I - I'm completely unemployed
you unemployed no [ __ ] is sitting here
guys sitting here and people like here's
five bucks here's ten bucks thrown it
into his empty guitar case good lord
this is what I should be doing [ __ ] yeah
I work for tips
I like like I was a busboy so I know how
to work for tips man I put them on the
glass for some tips and stuff like that
oh I'll be a cam boy for you aren't you
ready to play yes muffin fluffer we go
up up up up yeah yeah get that board
snake he has a snake is ah oh my god
listen here snake I hit him
don't you worry I hit him in the face
with his own skateboard yeah who brings
a [ __ ] hockey stick to the mall
Kabang don't you kick me I'll kick you
back now my friends here my both kick me
and Jason kids back in the day me and
Jason used to go to the mall together so
not only did we make that movie where we
went to the mall we actually did go to
the mall and hang out together we go to
the remember we go too lazy to store it
then go far remember we just go to mama
the mall and [ __ ] like that so when I
play this game I'm like wow we never
once had to get into I I heard that but
do they write it somewhere wanted a
podcast shout out but I don't see which
one it is can you say it again or write
it henceforth of Jason be used to fight
their way through the mall try to get
[Music]
you won't let me go I'm frozen I cuz the
board sorry it's called another oh he
killed me meeting you both and smoking
with Kevin I love both of y'all comic
book men changed my life and I regained
my love for the books oh that's awesome
all the joy Jay and Silent Bob did for
me and do weekly let smoke have face
time that is beautiful
I appreciate the shout-out be smoking
believing me is not difficult at all you
just have to find me I I enjoy smoking
weed and I don't mind smoking with
others I tend to smoke by myself in my
office a bunch while I'm writing because
I made a deal with myself like I didn't
become a STONER until I was 38 after
working with Seth Rogen on on Zack &
Miri Make a Porno
so I enjoyed weed so much I hadn't
really been a STONER prior to them
I enjoyed weed so much that I was like
I'm gonna start doing this all the time
and I'm a smoke every day and then it
got earlier and earlier and then I
became awake and Baker so I made a deal
with myself where I said if you're gonna
smoke weed you got to be doing something
while you're smoking weed so you know as
long as you're doing something creative
then nobody can give you [ __ ] about
smoking weed and stuff so make sure
you're recording a podcast make sure
you're making a movie right and a script
anything as long as you're being
creative then you could smoke as much
weed as you want I said to myself
because then nobody could say [ __ ] so if
you look at my pro yeah let me swing in
fists of fury and get that let me get
that
so if if you look at my work like 2009
forward I started doing a lot of other
things it's not just like let's make
movie I start getting really [ __ ]
super productive that had everything to
do with weed I was like I want to smoke
weed so I'm gonna be as productive as I
can be and it holds to this day I still
like to stay as busy as I can so that I
can smoke weed on a regular basis and
nobody will give me in the face oh my
god don't you get on that skin oh my god
kill me
daddy got the skateboard I'm glad you
killed him you deserve how could I do
that
number one I love artwork particularly
when it features us Louie boo Roadshow
if you want to send us stuff is there
Jeff in a dress yes extreme lives can
you put there it is the address yeah
bless is in the chat address is in the
chat beautiful how sweet how do you get
a message through to them on the screen
can't figure it out you just did George
McGavin we are we just read it here it
is the podcast is called the geekly lab
an article nonsense show hey everybody
listen to the geekly lab and vertical
nonsense show it's the only podcast that
I'm not hosting myself or what else we
go I know is watching from LA attended
vulgar thon in 2005 did that Q&A for the
mall rats and chasing a me special DVDs
you got shot that day ever get published
anywhere
for you guys Cheers thank you yes I
believe on the Mallrats
DVD that we did I had this little
yellowish cover I think it was for the
15 year anniversary I think that's where
the documentary went where we did the or
the QA like we had a screening at the at
the ArcLight I think it was in the dome
Cinerama Dome and they shot that Jim Jax
was there you were there I was there
mojo sir
and I think that is on the Mallrats DVD
the special edition Mallrats DVD god I
love this I can give people answers to
their questions your cutest enemy says
hey Kevin Smith is there any chance
you'll be coming to Michigan soon I want
to have you sign one of my hockey
jerseys Go Red Wings Gordie Howe yeah I
will be back in Michigan as soon as they
let us travel and do shows again you
know a big part of what we do for a
living
is shows you know Jane saw Bobby get old
we tour all over the world with it
so who knows what that's gonna look like
post pandemic you know audience is much
smaller and stuff like that but yeah as
soon as they let us get out believe me
we'll be going we were just in Michigan
not too long ago with the Jay and Silent
Bob reboot rope show tour so we go
around all the time
exelon shot says Kevin what is the
secret to your weight loss I went vegan
nobody wants to hear that sorry but I
used to be happy now I'm vegan and so
going vegan and instantly eliminates a
lot of things that you like to eat that
maybe aren't so good for you maybe pack
on the way that and I'm also an
intermittent faster I eat on a 20/4
daily diet schedule so that means I
don't eat for 20 hours and then I have a
feeding window of four hours when that
20 hours is up so I don't eat three
meals a day I don't never eat breakfast
I basically one meal a day and that's
really all the body needs in fact you
know you I could go every other day if I
really wanted to because I still got
stored energy that the body could feed
off of
so I've you know some people like off
you go if you have fast or you don't eat
the body will just eat your muscles
that's [ __ ]
you know just jump online you'll find
some science backs it up uh f
intermittent fasting a lot of [ __ ]
people doing it now we were not meant as
a species to eat three meals
you know we come from people our
ancestors who like we're lucky to eat
once a week and [ __ ] and we'll go out
hunting and stuff like that so I've
learned to relearn to eat and I just I
don't eat nearly as much don't even
breakfast and I don't eat pass like I
think now it's six o'clock graduating
from high school at the end of this
month do you have any words of wisdom
for the kids transitioning to the next
phase of their lives yeah I do haven't
been able to find your herb here in
Vegas our herb is in Vegas it's
definitely one of the places it's
available you can pop in there's a three
weed stores on the strip which carry our
snoogantay Zurcher and and bujji's thank
you he would know so yeah you could find
it go to the caviar gold website they'll
tell you where to find a caviar gold
fuels our weed as for people graduating
when we were kids they told us go to
college get a good job and that's how
you succeed in life that model is
shattered and it works for some but it's
not for everybody this is the best
advice I can give you find out what you
love to do in life and then figure out
how to get paid to do it if that happens
for you you'll be happy every [ __ ]
day of your life you'll love your job
it'll never be a job because it's
something you would have done anyway for
[ __ ] free so that's what I do that's
what he does to a lesser degree I'm
always trying to figure out like who I
like this like I liked hanging out with
Jason how do I get paid for this well we
make a movie and stuff like that
that way I get to do the [ __ ] I was
gonna do anyway and then hopefully we
can earn from it sometimes it means you
work for free though like we did Jay and
Silent Bob good old podcast for like
close to ten years and stuff and put
that up online so people could listen to
it for free but people want to see the
show in person they like paid and stuff
so sometimes your hobby can be turned
into a career could be turned into a job
but that's the best piece of advice I
have for figure out what you love to do
figure out how you pay for when you go
on the show and toke it up with Joe also
screw the haters
some in red state was genius my god
never get popular maybe I'll get on the
podcast with you guys please do I talked
to everybody
I believe me it's not I'm not selective
at all but thank you I want to go back
on Joe
soon I tend to do it once a year once
every other year on Joe Rogan we tend to
do long shows I think the longest we
ever did was like four hours and stuff
last one we did was two hours but I you
know I don't really I guess I don't have
that much to talk about although I would
love to go and [ __ ] with them about
please do plus one episode with danger
that's a good idea
oh my god we should totally do that
we're gonna do one of them so once found
said do you remember a Victor Garber or
talk to Victor day monopoly tomorrow you
put me up all around us times you put my
wait to see finished product of script
that you've finished Kevin sorry for
spoiler alert
sorry this dude swifters is dream where
him and I are gonna play Monopoly is a
video game or a boy that's a video board
game it's like you know it's a board
game but they make it real life just
like as though and you need more people
yeah I think you could plant a five or
six people so I don't know right now
it's me and Swifter
you're working on project you'd love to
include which superhero where do you see
it where do you see oh so I keep looking
over to the stream chat but it's there
has even asked you to do American
glutton not yet I hope so
he's got his own show
I love even Ethan got [ __ ] ripped
like oh my god when I saw a picture of
him online I was at holy heaven first
remember he got off then doing the bike
stuff like he was biking all the time he
fight to the mall resting that's right
and and he like but I mean like that's
was him like lean and shape but then he
start putting on mass right so his part
in Mallrats hopefully he comes out for
it and stuff Wham
hits you with a skateboard he's gonna be
the ripped security guard replacement
for the forest because look I've read
somebody read the script the other day
Liz one of our producers on the movie
I'm like shoes where we see what a great
question because we were afraid that
that would be the thing that would get
us an nc-17 so who you better get that
ice cream so we cut it in advance but I
loved that scene I wish we hadn't cut it
but it was probably the wise move that
way we didn't have to fight the ratings
board on that movie I was always
fighting the ratings for it back in the
bed you know they give you a like an
nc-17 for language and as a prohibitive
Brading yeah I'm glad that philosophy
Panza oh my I'm glad that philosophy
found pans out for others would always
panned out for me oh my god you ran me
over and he killed me you piece of [ __ ]
a cow and I [ __ ] don't eat you bro I
went vegan and I saved your life you're
gonna [ __ ] kick my ass now you're
dead let's do it this is the movie
killing round I'm [ __ ] done I'm done
[ __ ] around you know I'm saying this
[ __ ] hockey kid you touch me again I
swear to God get out of here yeah I love
that sound hmm
it's a good ass a man like why do people
need real like sweet graphics and
first-person-shooter ship this [ __ ] work
just fine for us all throughout the 80s
in the early 90s man tell the dragon
that [ __ ] man now we're working together
Kevin used to have
[Music]
nothing I kept trying to get it I did
have like I had the whole board at one
point but I mean miss stands a reason
because it was in my house but like
Affleck would come over and try to knock
me off the top spot Jason would come
over try knocking off the top spot I
like to have in the full board happy
birthday you essential worker Brian
thank you so much man you are doing the
work so we don't have to leave the house
that means the world man you're keeping
us safe
you're like a Batman happy birthday
Batman oh my god this cow just jumped me
jump me again
now I kick you in that [ __ ] you bum
steer
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh bah yeah we got [ __ ]
what time is it now 428 428 all right
next death I'm gonna have to go next
depth I gotta go kids cuz I gotta try to
secure work remember before I told you
I'm job unemployed and [ __ ] oh don't you
dare
now I hit you with your board over and
over again
[Music]
hey man thanks for that nobody ever
complements yoga hosers oh there's a
sock full of quarters
go ahead lady good mom thank you for
that and you know what be a director
it's fun anybody could do it punches
punches swirling punches whoa whoa I
think it's coming up to the ninja we are
this Patrick Swayze in the poster what
do you say but the rest you next watch
party you need to watch men I don't know
hey you guys do you remember which game
J sucked off in the rec center it was
asteroids he tried but there was no
joystick me to mall rats and clerks when
I was young she is amazing in loves you
both can you please say hello to Diane
poppy hey Diane poppy poppy i poppy
Diane poppy thank you for introducing
our kid your kid to our stuff all right
we're gonna go try to kick Patrick
Swayze's ass here we go get ready kids
all right I will I will if I can't I
gotta figure out the rights and how you
can do that I think it's on Amazon so it
should be okay yeah yeah you can totally
do it
you don't need no rights um you don't
need no stinking badges that'd be fun to
watch man I would watch along with that
Jason made an excellent movie here we go
any ran me over you know what we got to
our goal where we're like I saw you hit
him is make it mince meat of this oh
nobody puts Baby in a corner
well he just put bobbin in a corner
oh I kicked him in the [ __ ] mush we
only got 200 keep doing this could you
imagine if that was good times man oh
[ __ ] pause it I hit a button my mistake
good [ __ ] times man Jane saw Bob
playing games and stuff boy that was fun
all right I'm gonna go pitch the real
ante folks on a thing that hopefully
they let me do or you keep playing well
I got to see but I believe I'll be
streaming those six five thirty of these
so hopefully you know try to make this a
three-hour tour a three-hour to meeting
your wife yeah she'll be on the pitch as
well Jason's wife runs our company so
yeah she'll be on the pitch as well when
are you coming back Kevin since dragons
milk and when anytime Jay lets me come
over we'll do it again next week man
you know maybe we will because we got
boxes though yeah we do what's in the
box next but I'll come play it is we
could play like this weekend or we could
play this weekend - that - or that - Jay
working on script where zombie has his
heart stolen by a witch he travels
through dark Phil to get it back if it
comes through will you be in it reboot
made me hug my daughter says Genesis
thank you Jay said yes oh baby no
witches
Kevin you still have the huge TV in your
house I'd do 103 inches I'm praying it
doesn't die cuz it's been there for like
almost 10 years at this point so I'm
hoping it doesn't [ __ ] up you because
it's like life-sized it's bigger than a
human looks like the [ __ ] Han Solo in
carbonite block it's real big and [ __ ]
I loved this said skater fantasy why
thank you skater fantasy but why don't
you tell your skate rat friends and stop
kicking our asses in the mall really
hard to be alright man I'm gonna get out
of here reboot with funnies [ __ ] as Obi
oh geez cyber dog thank you if you're
looking for me kids you can find me over
at that Kevin Smith club.com I am
reading small rats all this week not
mall rats what I say with mall rats were
moose jaw's all this week on a show
called wake and bake oh oh look at us
full camera philetus [ __ ] right yeah
look I don't look too old
um there it is man thanks for hanging
out
thank you for letting me be here thank
you sir that Kevin Smith club kids and
what else am i doing Wednesday no I
guess this one this was it now on to the
pitch next week next one's gonna be
what's in the box but maybe this weekend
we'll be playing this I might come back
and we play on Saturday what's good day
sir asunder saturday or sunday sunday
sure because I think I would Saturday I
fix my it's your background everything
looks real cool thanks thanks I like
your setup this is awesome [ __ ]
supporting the brand and [ __ ] Brandon
Brad call him Brandon Brandon Muse
alright thanks everybody
I'm gonna go otherwise I'll keep reading
the board yeah good luck on a pitch says
the Mikey D show
fingers crossed alright I'm are you stop
it keep going
I'm gonna keep going Kevin you're gonna
see me in my no pants I'm not wearing
any pants
no I'm backcountry I'm wearing pants can
you imagine George like a [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen all right I'm gonna
get out of here thanks for having me man
Jane saw Bob for Jay and fer for what's
in the box
I've been Kevin Smith JC muse and what's
in the box has been glorious go get this
[ __ ] game or is it Steve
get this game I'm gonna come back on
Sunday and play some more bye everybody
don't forget if you
you